.
Sie ist mir aufgefallen.
Aber ich dachte,
das werde etwas für eine Nacht
und dann reise ich weiter.
"Oh mein Gott,
wie kann man nur so naiv sein?"
"Irgend so ein Typ
vom anderen Ende der Welt."
Wir waren die ganze Zeit
im Internet zusammen.
Ich brach alle Kontakte
mit anderen Personen ab.
Für mich war klar:
Das geht in Richtung Hochzeit.
* Herzschläge *
* Romantische Melodie *
# Take my hand, take me anywhere,
as long as you are there.
# Take my hand.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
# Together we will be
forever you and me.
Für die wahre Liebe
sei kein Weg zu weit, heisst es ja.
Dementsprechend
muss Katja Fitzes Liebe riesig sein,
denn sie ist dem Mann ihres Lebens
ans andere Ende der Welt gefolgt.
Nach Neuseeland.
(Das ist die Westküste
der Nordinsel Neuseelands.)
(Wir sind hier am Strand verabredet.)
Die Frage ist ...
... wo wir sie finden.
Ich weiss nur, dass sie blond ist,
und ihre Tochter ist auch blond.
Und AJ muss man wohl irgendwo da
draussen suchen und nicht am Strand.
Diese Person ist schon mal blond,
aber ohne Kind.
Ich glaube, das sind sie.
Sind wir hier richtig?
- Ja.
Katja? Mona, hallo.
Ich hatte schon Angst, dass ich
eine wildfremde Blondine anspreche.
Hey.
- AJ, great to meet you.
I'm Mona.
- Hi, Mona, how are things?
Very good.
Sagst du auch Hallo?
Hast du schon ein Eis bekommen?
Verstehst du Schweizerdeutsch?
Ich verstehe ein paar Bruchstücke.
Ich lebte eine Zeit lang in der
Schweiz, so verstehe ich ein wenig.
Ich weiss, wenn man über mich redet!
Wo habt ihr euch
das erste Mal getroffen?
Es war in Indonesien,
auch am Strand.
Es war auf Sumbawa.
How can you not remember?
Sumbawa.
Als ich ihn traf, dachte:
"Ah, Neuseeländer,
den werde ich nie mehr sehen."
Du dachtest also,
das sei einfach etwas Spass?
Genau, ein Ferienflirt.
Ich war damals auf Weltreise,
bestimmt schon etwa fünf Monate.
Nach sechs Monaten hätte ich nach
Hause sollen, zurück an die Uni.
Aber dann ... habe ich
das Ganze etwas verlängert.
(Katja ging noch mal in die Schweiz,
um ihr Studium abzuschliessen,
und 2014 zogen sie nach Auckland.)
(Heute wohnen sie drei Autostunden
von Auckland entfernt,
in Maunganui, direkt am Meer.)
Noch weiter raus?
Siehst du Papi? Dort draussen.
Ah!
- Runter? War das zu schnell?
(Die Neuseeländer sind,
wie wir Schweizer,
stolz auf ihre schöne Natur
und Landschaft.)
(Und sie sind
ein sportbegeistertes Volk.)
(Mit Katja und AJ steige ich auf
den Hausberg von Mount Maunganui.)
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Wie ist es bei euch?
Seid ihr euch ähnlich
oder gilt: Gegensätze ziehen sich an?
Sorry.
- Hey.
Wir sind beide
eher etwas ungeduldig.
Wir machen etwas
lieber heute als morgen.
Bei mir ist es manchmal zu sehr so,
dass ich nicht so viel
darüber nachdenke und sage:
"Das wird schon klappen."
Das ist vielleicht der Grund,
warum ich hier bin.
Ich denke nicht so sehr
über die Konsequenzen nach.
Ich werfe mich einfach rein.
Willst du sagen, du warst etwas naiv
und bist einfach hergekommen?
Zu einem gewissen Grad
vielleicht schon.
Ist das nötig für
solch einen Riesenschritt, so jung?
Ja, ich denke schon.
Und wenn man jung ist,
ist man tendenziell sowieso naiver.
Es gibt vielleicht einige,
die nicht so sind,
aber mit Anfang 20
ist man doch etwas naiv.
Yeah!
* Lachen *
Bist du mit Papi hochgerannt?
- Ja!
Deine Hände rutschen weg.
Du hältst dich ja gar nicht fest.
Wieso sprichst du mit ihr
Schweizerdeutsch und nicht Englisch?
Sicher mal wegen meiner Mutter.
Sie spricht zwar etwas Englisch,
aber nicht so gut.
Und auch, weil es meine Sprache ist
und meine ...
... Identität.
Oder ein Teil meiner Identität.
Deshalb ist mir wichtig,
dass sie Schweizerdeutsch versteht.
(Vor ein paar Jahren legte sich
ein Schatten über das Glück.)
(Katjas Vater starb plötzlich.)
(Seither ist Katjas Sehnsucht
nach der Schweiz grösser geworden.)
Warum?
Um mit meiner Familie zu sein und
weil ich nur noch meine Mutter habe.
Mein Vater ist gestorben.
Deshalb ... Ja, ihretwegen.
Und wegen Freunden.
Das wünschst du dir?
Das ist das, was du hier vermisst?
Ja, doch.
Ich werde ganz sentimental
hier oben.
(Mit zittriger Stimme) Damit sie ...
Ich sehe ja, wie sehr sie sie mag.
Das erste Enkelkind.
Sie verpasst so viel.
Und auch für mich.
Und AJ versteht das.
Er weiss, dass ich mehr Heimweh
habe, seit Narja hier ist.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Na?
Ja, schau mal, du Bohne!
Sag:
"Papi, du bist eine Nervensäge."
Kannst du das sagen?
- Nervensäge.
# Take my hand ...
Er stand so dort.
Das war wirklich ...
* Indianische Flötenklänge, Gesang *
(Brigitte und Jay hatten beide
eine Scheidung hinter sich,
als sie sich
im Internet kennenlernten.)
(Und beide
sind im Nachhinein überzeugt,
dass es genau so kommen musste.)
Beautiful, beautiful!
(Seit 2011 sind die Schweizerin
und der stolze Nakota verheiratet.)
(Brigitte war Köchin,
Jay war gelernter Verhaltenstrainer
und ist heute
als Lastwagenfahrer unterwegs.)
Bye, take care! Drive safe!
Bye, sweetie!
(Am Anfang mussten Brigitte und Jay
immer wieder
sprachliche Barrieren überwinden.)
(Aber im Alltag
und den Gewohnheiten der Nakota
hat sie sich sehr schnell
zurechtgefunden und wohlgefühlt.)
Diese Mokassins
sind ein Auftrag meines Schwagers.
Ich habe mir im Internet,
mit YouTube-Videos,
von denen es viele gibt,
beigebracht, wie man sie macht.
Das gehört zu den Aufgaben,
die mir Jay übergeben hat.
Solche Arbeiten ...
Es ist eigentlich eine Ehre,
wenn ein Familienmitglied
auf einen zukommt und sich wünscht,
dass man ihm
dieses oder jenes macht.
Das ist eine Ehre und man kann
eigentlich nicht Nein sagen.
* Sanfte Musik *
(Brigitte hat mit Jay ein
völlig neues Leben kennengelernt.)
(Und auch für Jay hat sich
dank Brigitte vieles verändert.)
Sie half mir,
wieder zu mir zu finden.
Ich war verloren, komplett zerstört
von der letzten Scheidung.
Brigitte ist super.
Sie lehrte mich Geduld, Liebe,
machte wieder
einen positiven Menschen aus mir.
Sie lehrte mich,
dass ich der bin, der ich bin.
Ich müsse nur wieder zu mir finden.
Und das stimmt.
Sie macht mich schon glücklich,
wenn ich an sie denke.
Das hier ist das Symbol
für meinen Namen.
Weisse Bärin aus der Ferne.
Te'handoa mato ska.
Mato heisst Bär.
Ska ist weiss.
Und te'handoa heisst so viel wie:
ist von weit entfernt hergekommen.
Und das ist Nakota.
Die verstorbene Frau meines
Schwiegervaters gab mir den Namen.
Denn sie sagte,
sie hätte das Gefühl,
dass ich diese innerliche
Bärenkraft besitze.
Und das muss ja stimmen, denn ich
bin schliesslich in Bern geboren!
Ich bin eher jemand,
der wissen will,
was morgen, übermorgen
oder in einer Woche läuft.
Hier in Neuseeland hingegen ...
... oder v.a. AJ
ist von dieser Surfkultur geprägt.
Es ist mehr so, dass man im Heute
lebt, das Heute ist wichtig.
Morgen ist morgen.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
(Auch im Paradies beginnt der Alltag
in aller Herrgottsfrühe.)
(Um 5.30 Uhr ist Katja
bereits aufgestanden.)
(Sie muss zur Arbeit.)
Ich hasse es,
die Spülmaschine auszuräumen.
Ähm ...
Es gibt eigentlich keine klare
Regel. Wer gerade Zeit hat.
Obwohl, mit dem Ausräumen warte ich
normalerweise, bis AJ es macht.
Meistens - denn ich hasse es.
Aber er macht wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen mehr im Haushalt,
wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Er ist auch besser.
Man muss es dem überlassen,
der es am besten macht.
Vielleicht mache ich es nicht
so gerne, weil ich 100 % arbeite.
Wenn ich mehr zu Hause wäre,
dann vielleicht ...
Nein, auch dann
wahrscheinlich nicht.
(Wenn Katja und ihre Familie
am Morgen aufstehen,
ist bei ihrer Mutter in der Schweiz
bereits Abend.)
(Und erst noch einer
mit einem Familienfest.)
Hoi.
- Sternli.
Hast du einen Stern?
Hoi.
- Hoi.
Hoi, Roger.
Hoi, Dani. Hoi, Judith.
Oh, Luisa! Hoi.
* Kindergeschrei *
Schau mal, hier ist Cedi.
Ich habe gesehen,
dass er jetzt läuft.
Wenn man ihre Cousinen
und Cousins sieht,
die jetzt alle viel grösser
als beim letzten Mal sind,
merkt man,
wie schnell die Zeit vergeht
und wie viel man verpasst
oder nicht sieht.
* Kindergeschrei *
(Frau)Pass auf, die Ecke!
Das ist dann ein bisschen traurig.
Nicht wahr, Narja?
Sagt du Oma noch Tschüss?
Sagst du Tschüss?
- Tschüss, Oma.
Tschüss.
* Schnelle, verspielte Musik *
Gehen wir, Schätzchen?
- Bye bye.
Einsteigen! Andere Seite.
(Der Alltag einer
berufstätigen Mutter mit Kleinkind
sieht, egal auf welcher Seite der
Erde, wohl überall etwas gleich aus.)
Und dann holt dich Papa ab?
Ja?
Okay.
Tschüss.
Tschüss!
- Bye.
Bye, see you later.
Yeah, you close it now? Good girl.
Er hat angefangen.
Wir haben gechattet,
aber es war sehr kurz:
"Du bist aus Kanada? Cool.
Ich bin aus der Schweiz." "Cool."
Fertig.
Dann nach ein paar Wochen wieder.
Und so begannen wir zu schreiben.
Wir hatten ähnliche Interessen.
Die Konversationen
wurde immer lustiger,
also wollten wir mal skypen.
Er log aber und sagte,
das Mikrofon sei kaputt,
weil er zu schüchtern war.
Ich musste also schreiben.
Aber wir begannen zu skypen
und merkten immer mehr,
dass wir dieselben Interessen
und Vorstellungen hatten.
Und dann machte er
den mutigen Schritt und sagte:
"Virtuell funktioniert es. Klappt
es auch, wenn wir uns treffen?"
Das hat dann aber ...
It took about five months?
Etwa fünf Monate später
kam er in die Schweiz.
Und dann ...
- Oui.
... funktionierte es sehr gut.
* Sanfte Melodie *
(So richtig glücklich ist David
in der Schweiz aber nicht geworden.)
(Deshalb versuchen sie es
jetzt umgekehrt.)
(Thomas Kleiber
packt seine Siebensachen
und zieht in ein paar Tagen
nach Quebec.)
Ja, vieles ist schon weg.
Viele Sachen konnte ich
meiner Familie überlassen
oder auch Freunden.
Einen Teil
habe ich sonst verscherbelt.
Es ist ziemlich ...
Ja, es ist kein Wohnzimmer mehr.
Aber den Tisch
behalte ich auf jeden Fall,
der gehörte meinem Grossvater.
Die Stühle kommen weg,
aber der Tisch ist super.
Mir ist schon bewusst,
dass es ein Abschied ist,
aber es ist ...
Wenn ich die Sachen wegräume,
die ich mit David zusammen hatte,
dann ist es etwas merkwürdig,
denn dann denke ich
an unsere schöne Zeit hier.
Aber die Wohnung selbst ...
Das Gehen ist etwas anderes. Das
Weggehen aus der Schweiz wird hart.
(Die ersten Schritte in
ein neues Leben mögen aufregend sein,
die letzten Schritte im alten Leben
sind aber auch nicht ohne.)
(Im Herbst 2018
steht Thomas Kleiber zum letzten Mal
in Zürich
auf dem Dach des Fernsehstudios.)
Im Norden am Samstag
z.T. auch Hochnebel.
Auch wenn die Details noch unsicher
sind im Lauf der neuen Woche,
klar ist, es bleibt mild.
Meine Damen und Herren,
jetzt muss ich intervenieren.
Wir müssen nämlich
Abschied von dir nehmen, Thomas.
Das war deine allerletzte
"Meteo"-Sendung.
Die Liebe zieht dich nach Kanada.
Du wirst auswandern.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
* Herzschläge *
Mein Ex-Mann war kein Fehler.
Am Anfang waren wir sehr glücklich.
Wir haben uns einfach
auseinandergelebt.
Aber es war nicht das,
was hätte sein sollen.
* Indianische Flötenklänge,
Gesang *
(Das, was hätte sein sollen,
sieht so aus.)
(Die Weite der Prärie, das Gefühl
der Freiheit, die Nähe zur Natur
und Jay an ihrer Seite.)
Yeppa, sweet pea.
Let's sit right there.
Come on, old girl, you can do it.
There you go, woman.
How pretty that is!
(Bevor die Köchin aus Bern
und der Verhaltenstherapeut vom Stamm
der Nakota zueinanderfanden,
brauchte es aber nicht nur
einen Wink des Schicksals,
sondern auch den Segen
der modernen Technik.)
* Kauzrufe *
Unsere Geschichte begann damit:
Ich hatte eine Freundin,
die mir von Match.com erzählte.
Und zwar nicht nur, um einen Partner
für eine Beziehung zu finden,
sondern einfach Bekanntschaften -
socialising.
Ich habe ein bisschen rumgestöbert
und habe Jays Profil gesehen.
Und sein Lachen und seine
strahlenden Augen gefielen mir.
Ich dachte:
"Dem muss ich schreiben!"
Ich hatte ein Dreitages-Probeabo.
Da musst du nichts bezahlen.
Du kannst dein Profil erstellen
und ein Foto hochladen.
Ich habe das
an einem Freitag gemacht.
Und am Sonntag haben wir schon
ausserhalb der Plattform
miteinander geschrieben.
Wir haben uns hin und her
geschrieben, über Alltägliches.
Fragen wie:
"Was machst du? Was arbeitest du?"
"Wo wohnst du?"
Und das für mehr als neun Monate.
Wir hatten vorher
nie miteinander gesprochen.
Dann stand ich am Flughafen,
und als sie runterkam, dachte ich:
"Wow, wie auf dem Foto!"
Sie kam auf mich zu
und ich stand nur da.
Dann habe ich ihren Arm berührt
und es fühlte sich an
wie ein elektrischer Schlag.
Wir schauten uns an und ich fragte:
"Hast du das auch gespürt?"
Und sie sagte Ja.
Boom!
Und dann
küsste ich sie auf den Mund,
und ich wusste, dass es
die Wahrheit war, als ich ihr sagte:
"Ich werde dich heiraten."
Natürlich glaubte sie mir das nicht,
aber ich heiratete sie dann.
Und jetzt bin ich glücklich.
* Schleppende Gitarrenklänge *
* Herzschläge *
Säntis. Here it is.
Yeah, on top of the mountain.
So, no, it was ...
Up on top of a Swiss mountain.
Die Katze war schon im Sack.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
(Katja ist Ökonomin
und hat an der HSG studiert.)
(Sie arbeitet Vollzeit
bei der Bank of New Zealand
als Beraterin für Grosskunden.)
- Happy birthday!
Oh, is it your birthday?
Oh!
Oho!
Roger.
Aber wie ist es eigentlich?
Wir haben hier
ein Stück Schweiz in Neuseeland,
aber du willst ja vielleicht zurück -
schaust du dich nach Jobs um?
Ich habe mal
meine Fühler ausgestreckt,
um zu sehen, wie schwierig
oder wie einfach es wird.
Ich glaube, es ist etwas schwierig
von so weit weg.
Aber wenn ich einen Job finde,
dann wäre auch AJ dabei.
Das ist die Voraussetzung:
Ich muss einen Job finden.
Also "müssen",
ich bin ja diejenige, die arbeitet,
und er ist der Stay-at-home-dad.
Wenn ich ihn vor
vollendete Tatsachen stellen kann,
dann ist es perfekt.
(Ich glaube, die beiden haben
noch einiges zu diskutieren.)
I'm hiding.
- Where are you?
(AJ war lange Zeit Surfprofi, jetzt
ist er im Wesentlichen Hausmann
oder Stay-at-home-dad,
wie es hier heisst.)
Katja ist
ein bisschen strenger als ich.
Narja und ich sind entspannter,
wir essen Eis
und hängen ein bisschen rum.
Nicht wahr, Narja? Wir sagen Mama
nicht, dass wir Eis essen.
Aber du verrätst uns immer!
Es ist wichtig,
für sie da zu sein,
ihr die wichtigen Sachen
beizubringen,
ihr das Gefühl
von Liebe und Sicherheit zu geben.
Ich glaube,
sie hat hier, was sie braucht.
(Etwas, das AJ selbst nicht hatte.)
(Seine Mutter verliess die Familie,
als er noch zur Schule ging.)
Do you want the unicorn?
Schlaf gut.
* Fröhliche, entspannte Musik *
Ich mache die Dinge gern schnell.
Just get it over with.
Ich mag keine Unordnung,
sondern Sauberkeit.
Katja ist anders, sie macht sogar
mehr Durcheinander als Narja.
Da braucht es jemanden,
der auf die beiden aufpasst.
(Feierabend ist Familienzeit.)
(Diese verbringen Katja, AJ und Narja
häufig am Strand.)
Narja, to the beach we go!
(Hier fühlt sich AJ am wohlsten.)
Kannst du es verantworten,
jemanden wie ihn vom Meer wegzuholen
in die Schweiz?
Ich habe ein wenig
ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Es ist nicht nur ein Hobby,
sondern wirklich ein Lebensstil.
Meine Mutter sagt immer:
"Irgendwann wächst er doch da raus."
"Er kann ja in der Schweiz
snowboarden." Oder sonst etwas.
Aber das ist, als würde man
einem Bündner die Berge wegnehmen.
Der fühlt sich auch nicht wohl
oder bekommt schnell Heimweh.
Einer von euch muss immer
Kompromisse eingehen.
Einer ist immer
ein bisschen unglücklich.
Entweder bist du weit von der Schweiz
weg, oder er ist weg vom Meer.
Kompromisse muss man
in jeder Partnerschaft eingehen,
aber in so einer
internationalen Partnerschaft
sind es vielleicht noch grössere
Kompromisse, die man eingeht.
Aber letztlich
sollte man sie gerne eingehen
und man sollte es wollen,
denn es bedeutet, dass man mit der
Person zusammen ist, die man will.
Irgendwie glaube ich,
dass es einen Grund gibt,
warum ich nicht jemanden aus
dem Appenzellerland gefunden habe.
Und mit dem Thurgauer Dialekt
findet man auch nicht so viele.
Hör auf, nein!
Ich habe auch einen gefunden.
Das ist jetzt die neueste These:
Mit Thurgauer Dialekt
muss man bis nach Neuseeland,
denn dort merken sie es nicht.
Danke, Katja!
Hier hat mich noch nie jemand
wegen meines Dialektes angesprochen.
(Ja, das hat gesessen!)
(Aber hier am Strand
von Mount Maunganui
fallen einem schon noch
ein paar andere Gründe ein,
warum man das Leben in Neuseeland
und nicht zwingend
im Kanton Thurgau verbringen will.)
Yeah!
- Woohoo!
# Take my hand.
Als ich sie gesehen habe,
war sie vom Aussehen her ...
Sie ist wahnsinnig hübsch, schön
und eben auch sympathisch,
wir haben dieselben Interessen.
Sportlich.
Ja, damals waren wir noch sportlich.
Und ja, daher war mir
von Anfang an klar ...
Ich hatte zu jener Zeit,
als wir miteinander skypten,
noch andere Kontakte im Osten.
Ich hatte weitere Kontakte
in der Ukraine und in Russland.
Sobald ich mit ihr
ins Gespräch gekommen war,
mit ihr in Kontakt gekommen war,
war mir klar, dass ich
die anderen Kontakte abblocke
und dass ich das mit ihr
ernsthaft verfolge.
(Martin und Lana verliebten sich
vor sieben Jahren übers Internet
und heirateten bald darauf.)
(Seither wohnen sie in Thusis.)
(Lana stammt aus der Ukraine.)
Okay.
Das geht jetzt ...
... in den Ofen.
(Martin ist überzeugter Vegetarier.)
Lana kocht sehr gut.
Ich könnte schon selbst kochen,
aber es ist natürlich viel bequemer,
wenn man nur wenig Zeit über Mittag
hat und nicht selber kochen muss
und sich einfach hinsetzen kann.
Das ist gut.
Und die Idee war ja auch, dass ...
5 Min., okay?
... dass sie Hausfrau ist.
(V.a. seit ihr gemeinsamer Sohn Leon
auf der Welt ist.)
(Wenn man sich wie Lana und Martin
übers Internet kennenlernt,
kann man schon vor dem ersten Treffen
die Rahmenbedingungen abstecken
und Wünsche anbringen.)
(Deshalb haben sich die beiden
schon früh über Kinder unterhalten.)
Wo ist hier "ten"? Ich seh's nicht.
Sie hat ja bereits
einen älteren Sohn.
Als ich sie per Skype kennenlernte,
war mir das im Prinzip egal.
"Okay, wenn sie keine Kinder will,
dann eben nicht. Okay."
Und dann ...
... haben wir uns doch entschieden,
ein Kind zu bekommen.
Es war v.a. mein Wunsch
und sie fand dann:
"Gut, dann machen wir das noch mal."
Aber für sie war es natürlich
schon noch happig,
nachdem sie gedacht hatte:
"Mein ältester Sohn ist ausgeflogen,
mit Kindern habe ich
nichts mehr zu tun."
Für sie war es dann doch etwas
schwierig, in diesem Alter ...
Papa, schau!
- Cool.
... noch mal eine Schwangerschaft
einzugehen und ein Kind aufzuziehen.
Was machst du jetzt?
Leon, was ist das?
- "Blue".
Ja, aber was "blue"?
Ich weiss nicht,
was du hier machst.
Lana?
- Ja, ja, wir essen gleich.
Ich muss dann irgendwann
arbeiten gehen.
Was ist?
- Ich muss arbeiten.
Okay, vielleicht
kannst du schon mal anfangen.
Ja, eben.
- 5 Min.
(Seit 22 Jahren ist Martin
Oberstufenlehrer in Thusis.)
(Wegziehen
kam für ihn nicht infrage.)
(Schon gar nicht in die Ukraine.)
Meiner Ansicht nach
haben wir ein ganz tolles System
mit unserer Demokratie, mit
unserem Wirtschaftssystem und allem.
Und auch politisch
ist die Lage sicher.
Ich sehe keinen Grund,
woanders zu leben.
Und für sie
war es eigentlich auch klar.
Sie wollte eher weg aus der Ukraine.
You wanted to leave the Ukraine?
Live or leave?
Leave, go out.
- Ja, ja.
Ich habe meine Familie aufgegeben,
die dort geblieben ist.
Ich habe
meinen Lebensstil aufgegeben,
meine ...
... das ganze Sozialleben,
das ich dort hatte.
Freundinnen,
die ich seit 20, 30 Jahren habe.
Unsere Kinder
sind zusammen aufgewachsen.
Man gibt sein Leben auf,
den Lebensstil,
den man zu jenem Zeitpunkt lebt.
Ich war erstaunt
und fühlte mich sehr geliebt.
Ich fragte mich,
ob ich dasselbe getan hätte,
und ich bin nicht sicher,
ob ich das damals gekonnt hätte.
* Indianische Flötenklänge *
(Brigitte hat zwei Töchter.)
(Diese sind in der Schweiz geblieben,
als Brigitte
alles hinter sich gelassen hat
und zu Jay in die USA gezogen ist.)
... damit es nicht zu trocken ist.
Heiratsanträge müssen doch
immer toll und pompös sein.
Aber meiner war einfach
so besonders,
wie unsere Ehe es ist.
Er hatte gerade geduscht,
er kam raus,
nur das Handtuch um sich,
und kniete mit nassen Haaren
vor mir nieder
und machte mir einen Heiratsantrag.
Ich fand das so mega cool.
Es war einfach so spontan.
Nicht ... nicht geplant
und ohne grosses Tamtam
oder was weiss ich was.
Es war einfach spontan.
Er wusste einfach:
"Ich will das machen."
Ja.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Aufregend.
Und v.a. auch
die eigentliche Zeremonie.
Ich dachte: "Oh, das habe ich
schon oft im Film gesehen."
Weil es auf Englisch war,
war es genau so wie in den Filmen.
Native Americans
sollten nicht weinen.
Aber ich habe geweint an diesem Tag.
Aus lauter Glück.
Ich gebe es ungern zu.
Aber es stimmt,
ich war so glücklich.
Deine Haare waren
noch ganz schön schwarz.
There was nothing on the walls.
No, I'm talking about
your black hair.
Oh. Oh, yeah.
But I love that grey hair in here.
It looks beautiful.
* Lachen, Kuss *
En Guete.
- Good morning.
Guten Appetit.
- Excellent, baby.
Ach ja, das fehlt noch!
Ein kleines, kleines bisschen -
gegen das Heimweh.
* Herzschläge *
# Take my hand.
Sie macht gern Pläne
und ich schaue, was passiert.
Die Dinge ändern sich,
man kann gar nicht planen.
Das ist
wie das neuseeländische Wetter,
das wechselt auch alle 5 Min.
Ich gehe es langsam an
und verstehe gar nicht,
warum sie immer so gestresst ist.
Es kommt immer alles gut,
und wenn nicht,
dann findet sich eine Lösung.
Ein Plan B.
Man kann nicht
zu viele Pläne machen im Leben.
Ein paar.
- Ein paar, ja.
* Blöken *
(Auckland,
die grösste Stadt Neuseelands.)
(Hier wohnt ein grosser Teil
von AJs Verwandtschaft.)
(Sie sind ein wichtiger Anker für AJ,
aber auch für Katja.)
Sie wohnen alle hier?
- Genau.
Sie haben es gekauft,
aber dann auch noch viel angebaut.
Dieses Glas ist Judes ganzer Stolz.
Das ist noch neu.
Ja.
(Grandma Jude
ist eigentlich AJs Tante
und so etwas wie die neuseeländische
Ersatzmutter für Katja.)
(Eine Frau mit viel Familiensinn,
einem grossen Herzen
und vier Schwiegertöchtern.)
Gross!
Grossartig. Sie ist wirklich
eine grossartige Frau.
Ich wüsste nicht,
was ich hier ohne sie machen würde.
Sie ist die Beste.
Sie ist wirklich
meine Mutter in Neuseeland.
Ja, sie ist Gold wert.
Auch meine Mutter ist froh,
dass ich hier noch eine Mutter habe.
Ja, Schätzchen?
Du willst schwimmen gehen?
Ziehen wir die Badehosen an?
* Liebliche Musik *
Girls,
I want to introduce you to Mona.
Nice to meet you. I'm Mona.
Mona is here from Switzerland.
This is my other beautiful
daughter-in-law, Gina.
Nice to meet you.
* Donnern *
Yeah, but people
are doing side angles.
And you're diving.
(AJ hatte eine schwierige Kindheit.)
(Nachdem seine Mutter
die Familie verlassen hatte,
wurde seine Grossmutter
zur wichtigsten Bezugsperson.)
(Sein Vater, ein Maori,
starb schon früh bei einem Unfall.)
(Jetzt hat AJ selbst ein Kind
und ist für Narja
ein präsenter und liebevoller Vater.)
Hast du dich verändert,
als du Vater geworden bist?
Ja, das geschieht wohl allen,
aber das ist eine gute Veränderung.
In what way?
Man hat
eine neue Sicht auf die Dinge,
man kann nicht nur
auf sich selber achten
und tun und lassen, was man will.
Da gibt es jemand anderen zu Hause.
Das ist gut.
My turn now!
- Okay.
Wait on, wait on!
Don't let her hit you.
That's as high
as you can go right now.
(Mit etwa 20 Jahren, als nach dem
Vater auch seine Grossmutter starb,
geriet AJs Leben
kurzfristig aus den Fugen.)
You need to share.
(Damals hat ihn Jude
in ihre grosse Familie geholt.)
This is basil from my garden.
Ich habe hart gearbeitet, um ihn
in unsere Familie zu integrieren.
Wir wollten ihn unbedingt
genau gleich behandeln
wie unsere anderen Kinder.
Was denkst du, werden AJ und Katja
zurück in die Schweiz gehen,
um dort zu leben?
Für immer?
I would love for that to happen,
but ...
Nein, das glaube ich leider nicht.
AJ kann Neuseeland nicht verlassen.
Das hat mit seiner Kindheit zu tun.
Ihm fehlt die Geborgenheit.
Das wird wohl sehr hart für Katja.
Eine grosse Herausforderung
für ihre Ehe.
Wenn man frisch verliebt ist,
denkt man,
man könne das Leben zu zweit
auf einer einsamen Insel verbringen,
aber mit den Jahren
zeigt sich eine andere Realität.
I will see you later.
Bye bye, love you!
Bye.
Take care, drive safely!
I'll text you
when we're on our way back.
(Das Naturwunder von Rotorua -
Schlammtümpel,
Geysire und heisse Quellen.)
(Und über allem liegt
der intensive Geruch von Schwefel.)
* Verspielte Klänge *
Jetzt so aus der Distanz betrachtet:
Eine Beziehung mit einem Mann von
der anderen Seite der Welt zu führen,
ist es einfacher oder schwieriger
geworden, als du dachtest?
Hm, gute Frage.
* Seufzen *
Das Schwierige,
auf jeden Fall für mich,
ist eigentlich nur, dass ich
meine Familie und Freunde vermisse.
Aber in unserer Beziehung ...
... gibt es
nicht viele Schwierigkeiten,
weil wir
aus verschiedenen Ländern stammen.
Es ist mehr die Distanz
zu meiner Familie und meiner Heimat.
Hättest du gedacht,
dass du solches Heimweh bekommst?
Nein, und am Anfang
hatte ich nie Heimweh.
Erst als ...
... mein Vater starb,
ganz plötzlich durch einen Unfall.
In solchen Situationen fährt es
richtig ein, wenn man weit weg ist.
Und dann ...
Eine schwierige Zeit für dich.
- Ja.
Dann überlegt man sich doch:
"Uff ..."
"Ist das wirklich ..."
Und wenn jemand Nahestehendes,
eben ein Elternteil stirbt
und man nur noch einen hat,
dann ist es
auch noch mal schwieriger.
Man entwickelt Schuldgefühle.
Hast du Schuldgefühle?
- Ja.
Deiner Mutter gegenüber?
Ja, ziemlich oft. Sorry.
Ja.
- Aber ...
Kommt das von dir selbst oder
vermittelt sie dir dieses Gefühl?
Nein, an ihr
liegt es überhaupt nicht.
Die macht man sich einfach -
oder ich.
Und jetzt mit ihr noch stärker,
denn man sieht, wie sehr sie sie mag
und wie wenig sie mitbekommt,
weil sie sie höchstens
ein bis zwei Monate am Stück sieht
und dann wieder ganz lange nicht.
Und schnell ist wieder ein Jahr rum.
Narja wächst so schnell
und vergisst auch schnell.
Das ist hart für sie. Und für mich.
Ich mag die Schweiz, es ist
mein Heimatland, ich bin Schweizer.
Das ist man automatisch,
und all das zurückzulassen,
z.B. auch ...
Das Selbstbewusstsein - im eigenen
Land versteht man die Sprache,
man versteht,
wie das Land funktioniert.
Man weiss, wie man sich in einem
Land verteidigt und platziert.
Man kennt die Spielregeln.
All das lässt man zurück -
man kommt in ein fremdes Land,
man ist quasi schwach,
unsicher und verletzlich.
Ja, das.
Grüezi wohl.
Soll ich das als Erstes?
- Ich gebe es Ihnen gleich so.
Ich brauche Ihren Pass.
(Thomas Kleiber wandert für
seinen Mann David nach Kanada aus.)
(Den Job beim "SRF Meteo"
hat er gekündigt,
die Wohnung geräumt
und sich von allen verabschiedet.)
Kein Korkenknallen.
Ciao. Tschüss.
Mach's gut! Bis nächstes Jahr.
- Danke, bis bald.
Ciao, Thöme.
- Tschüss.
Ähm ... Christian.
Ciao, Thömi.
- Vielen Dank.
Mach's gut!
(Abschied von den Eltern,
dem Bruder - und dann auf und davon.)
(Auf Thomas wartet zwar sein Mann,
aber sonst sehr viel Ungewohntes.)
(Z.B. wohnen sie
im Haus der Schwiegereltern
in Davids ehemaligem Kinderzimmer.)
(Wie er mit diesen neuen Umständen
zurechtkommt,
weiss er selbst
noch nicht so richtig.)
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
(Bei Katja und AJ in Neuseeland
sieht das Leben auf den ersten Blick
immer ein bisschen wie Ferien aus.)
(Zumindest wenn man
aus der Schweiz kommt
und sich das Meer vor der Haustür
nicht gewohnt ist.)
Are you alright?
(Aber heute ist wirklich
ein entspannter Tag für die beiden.)
(Die Bankfachfrau aus dem Thurgau
und der Surfartikelhändler
mit Maori-Wurzeln
geniessen einen freien Tag -
Tochter Narja ist bei Verwandten.)
Kommt es oft vor,
dass ihr Tage für euch allein habt?
Nicht sehr oft.
Ohne Narja eigentlich nie.
Never?
- No.
Wir haben keine Verwandten,
wo wir wohnen,
so ist sie immer mit uns zusammen.
Es wäre natürlich schön,
wenn ab und zu Grosseltern da wären,
die sie hüten könnten.
* Lockere Gitarrenklänge *
Do you see him already?
- Here we go! A snapper.
(Onkel Greg,
der für AJ ein Ersatzvater ist,
hat zum Fischen eingeladen.)
How big is it?
Oh, it'll be 40 cm.
Geht das immer so schnell?
Oh, nein!
Wir waren auch schon fischen
und haben gar nichts gefangen.
Deshalb finde ich Fischen
gar nicht so toll.
Ach so! Ich dachte,
du seist völlig begeistert.
Ich fange jeden Abend
mein Nachtessen ... Nein!
Ich denke,
ich werde nie genau gleich werden.
Das wird man nie, wenn man nicht
aus dem Land stammt, egal woher.
Die Schweiz ist mein Zuhause,
auch wenn ich hier lebe.
Ich sehe mich nicht
als Neuseeländerin,
ich bin immer noch voll Schweizerin.
Solltest auch du mal gerne fischen,
sprechen wir noch mal darüber!
Genau.
What?
Oh!
- Oh, ein Hai!
Do you keep it
or do you let it go?
Is it slimy?
- No, no.
Wow!
Okay, bye-bye!
- Bye, baby shark!
He can come back
and eat these other fish.
Könntest du in einem Land wie der
Schweiz leben, weit weg vom Meer?
Eine schwierige Vorstellung,
so für immer.
What are you looking over at me?
Mit einem Seitenblick zu dir!
Das diskutieren wir gerade.
Vielleicht nicht für immer,
aber für eine gewisse Zeit.
Für eine Weile ginge das schon.
Ich war in der Schweiz,
es ist schön da.
Aber für immer?
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
(Und dann fischt sie
eben doch noch - Katja.)
(Es braucht Kompromisse, wenn
sich zwei so lieben wie Katja und AJ,
aber aus verschiedenen Welten
kommen.)
(Dass sie für immer
zusammensein wollen, wissen sie.)
(Aber ob in Neuseeland
oder in der Schweiz -
diese Frage wird sie wohl
ein Leben lang begleiten.)
# Take my hand.
(Für mich ist es Zeit, Adieu zu sagen
und zu danken für diesen Einblick
in das Leben
auf der anderen Seite der Welt.)
# Together we will be
forever you and me.
Ich wollte nie sagen,
dass ich Schweizer bin,
denn ich habe das Gefühl,
im Ausland wird das
schnell falsch interpretiert.
"Du bist Schweizer?
Du bist Millionär."
"Nein, ich bin bloss Schweizer,
es dauert noch etwas,
bis ich Millionär bin."
Also habe ich einen Italiener
gespielt, das kommt immer gut an.
Ich sagte ihr:
"Io sono italiano. Komm her!"
Si.
* Schwungvolle mexikanische Musik *
(Nancy und Demis sind 31
und seit vier Jahren verheiratet.)
(Sie leben dort,
wo es für sie gerade zu tun gibt.)
(Im Moment sind sie
in Monterrey in Mexiko.)
(Dort, wo Nancy aufgewachsen ist.)
(Nancy hat in Mexiko
Psychologie studiert,
Demis hat in Zürich eine Banklehre
und die Berufsmatura gemacht.)
(Bis die beiden ein Paar wurden,
waren einige Etappen nötig.)
(Heute zeigen uns
Demis und Nancy einen Ort,
der für Mexiko typisch ist.)
(Arm und Reich trifft sich
am Sonntag auf dem Markt.)
Jeden Sonntag wird hier gespielt.
Man hört sie am anderen Ende rufen.
Man denkt, es sei ein Fussballspiel,
aber es ist nur Bingo.
* Rufe auf Spanisch *
Es geht nicht ums grosse Geld.
Sie spielen, damit sie
zu Hause genug zu essen haben.
Sie bekommen z.B. Milch, Cola, Reis.
Teigwaren, Putzmittel.
Alles Dinge,
die man zu Hause braucht.
Vielleicht gewinnen wir WC-Papier,
das ist immer gut.
(Vor neun Jahren
hat Demis sein Bankerleben
samt Anzug und Krawatte
abgestreift,
hat sich von seinen Eltern,
die gerade in der Trennung waren,
verabschiedet und ist aufgebrochen,
um die Welt zu entdecken.)
Ich war damals noch unterwegs,
meine erste Weltreise,
nachdem ich die Berufsmatura
abgeschlossen hatte.
Ich war schon
eineinhalb Jahre unterwegs,
als ich auf sie gestossen bin,
in Puerto Vallarta,
eher im Süden Mexikos
an der pazifischen Küste.
Ich sah sie in einem Club
beim Tanzen.
Ich stand draussen ...
... und verliebte mich
gleich visuell.
(Demis musste um die Liebe kämpfen.)
(Nancy wollte erst
gar nichts von ihm wissen.)
(Er konnte nur
ihre Telefonnummer erobern.)
* Fröhliche Musik *
Sie hat mir
eine so extreme Abfuhr erteilt,
dass es meinem Ego so geschadet hat,
dass ich es nicht
auf mir sitzen lassen konnte.
Nach einem Tag
ging sie zurück nach Monterrey,
das 25 Busstunden
von hier entfernt ist.
Ich bin ihr einfach
nach Monterrey gefolgt.
25-26 Std. mit dem Bus.
Ich habe ihr geschrieben:
"Hey, rate mal, wo ich bin!"
"Ja, wo bist du jetzt wieder?"
"Ich bin hier in Monterrey."
Und sie so: "Was?"
"Mein Gott, das ist ein Psychopath,
der will mich vergewaltigen."
"Das ist ein mega schlimmer Typ."
No? Pensabas que soy un maníaco?
- Sí.
(Aber dank seinem Charme öffnen sich
Haustür und kurz danach auch Herzen
von Nancy
und der ganzen Familie Cortez.)
(Das ist achteinhalb Jahre her.)
(Und jetzt besuche ich Demis
und Nancy im Haus ihrer Eltern.)
825?
Hat es denn hier irgendwo Nummern?
Ah! Okay.
* Bellen *
Hola!
- Hola!
La madre de Nancy?
- Nancy.
Ah! Soy Mona.
Hermosa?
- Tu.
Oh! Muchas gracias.
Tu nombre?
Rosi.
- Rosi? Also. Mona.
* Rosi spricht spanisch. *
Vielen Dank!
Ciao!
- Hoi. Ich bin Mona.
Freut mich, Demis. Ich habe
nasse Haare, habe gerade geduscht.
Kein Problem.
Man wird gleich geherzt und umarmt.
Das ist Mambino? Hoi!
Hallo!
- Hola, Mona.
Freut mich sehr.
How are you? Good?
(All diese Menschen
treffe ich heute zum ersten Mal.)
(Aber schon nach 5 Min. wurde ich
in Mexiko mehr umarmt und geküsst
als in der Schweiz
in einer ganzen Woche.)
Für mich ist das
der erste Mexiko-Besuch.
Kannst du ihnen sagen:
Ich möchte gerne noch mehr sehen,
wie man in Mexiko lebt.
* Sie sprechen spanisch. *
Die Liebe der Leute,
dass du die siehst.
Das wirst du gleich merken,
wenn du aus dieser Tür gehst.
(Und noch etwas erfahre ich bald:
dass man hier ganz offen umgeht
mit den Gefühlen - den schönen,
aber auch mit den schweren.)
Kennst du Enchiladas?
Das sind rote Tortillas.
Darauf kommt ...
- ... Chili.
Das ist Chili.
- Okay. Muy picante?
No picante.
- No picante?
Nein, es ist eher eine Tomatensauce.
- Das ist nicht so scharf.
Scharf ist es dann auf dem Markt,
wenn wir probieren gehen.
Ist das für Schweizer?
- Ja, sie hat Rücksicht genommen.
Auf welchem Schärfe-Niveau bist du?
Ich bin schon auf einem
sehr hohen Schärfe-Niveau.
Ich bin jetzt
in einem mexikanischen Prozess.
Als sie dich zum ersten Mal gesehen
hat, was dachte sie, ganz ehrlich?
* Demis spricht spanisch. *
Zuerst ist mir aufgefallen,
dass er anders ist.
Ich habe sofort gewusst, dass er
der Ehemann meiner Tochter wird.
Warum?
Er hat mich entzückt, verzaubert.
Ich liebe ihn wie einen Sohn.
* Sie sprechen spanisch. *
Ich empfinde sie auch als Mutter.
Ich dachte, das sei unmöglich,
die Schwiegermutter so zu lieben
wie die eigene Mutter.
(Dass die Verbundenheit so tief ist,
hat vielleicht noch einen
anderen Grund - einen traurigen.)
(Als Demis vor fünf Jahren zum
zweiten Mal zu Nancy nach Mexiko kam,
war Familie Cortez tief erschüttert.)
(Eric, Nancys 19-jähriger Bruder,
hatte sich kurz davor
das Leben genommen.)
Es gab eine 180°-Wende.
Die Situation war ziemlich planlos.
Man hatte zuerst keine Lebenslust.
Wir wussten nicht,
wofür wir noch leben sollten.
Aber wir wissen,
dass er hier präsent ist,
und wir wissen, dass wir irgendwann
alle zusammenkommen werden.
* Melancholische Flötenmusik *
* Schluchzen *
Sie sagte vorhin, es wäre schön,
wenn er jetzt auch hier wäre.
Es ist gerade
während dieser Festtage passiert.
Im Monat November.
Es ist schön, dass du hier bist,
dass ihr hier seid,
denn das ist eine Ablenkung für uns.
Das waren seine liebsten Festtage,
der Tag der Toten.
Das hat uns alle
in eine Depression gestürzt.
Zugleich weiss man:
Das Leben ist kurz.
Sie leben jeden Tag,
als ob es der letzte wäre.
Sie planen nicht: "So viel Geld
habe ich auf der Seite",
sondern sie geben es gleich aus.
Sie leben heute, weil morgen
vielleicht gar nicht mehr existiert.
* Melancholische Flötenmusik *
* Herzschläge *
* Er spricht französisch. *
Woran ich mich erinnere:
dass ich bei unserem ersten Treffen
viel gestresster
und verkrampfter war,
als ich es mir je vorgestellt hätte.
Und woran ich mich bei ihm
erinnern kann, als wir uns umarmten:
dass er einen Herzschlag
von ca. 10'000 hatte.
Ich konnte nicht glauben, dass
ein Herz so schnell schlagen kann.
Das ist mir aufgefallen:
wie schnell sein Herz schlägt.
Dass da also jemand
sehr, sehr aufgeregt ist.
* Liebliche Gitarrenmusik *
(Meteorologe Thomas Kleiber wusste,
worauf er sich einlässt,
wenn er zu David
und dessen Familie zieht:
auf den berüchtigten,
endlosen Winter von Quebec
und das Wohnen im Untergeschoss
im Haus der Schwiegereltern.)
* Summen *
So.
- On va allumer les lumières un peu.
Oui.
- Ça.
On doit le bouger.
Okay.
I have two long underwears.
(Es erinnert ein wenig an die
Wohnsituation einer Teenager-Liebe,
so im Soussol des Elternhauses.)
Natürlich
ist es nicht meine Wohnung,
ich kann nicht das gleiche Chaos
machen wie zu Hause.
Ich habe zumindest das Gefühl,
ich sollte nicht.
Was vielleicht
auch nicht schlecht ist.
Aber ...
Es ist natürlich eine Umstellung.
Ich habe momentan
auch keinen festen Beruf,
muss meine Hobbys
hier neu definieren.
Das ist es, was mich einschränkt,
dass ich so ein wenig abhängig ...
Oder wie soll ich sagen?
Eine Zeit lang nicht mein ...
Ich muss mich wieder finden.
Das ist aber auch toll.
Man kann alte, blöde Dinge aufgeben
und neue anfangen.
Das ist es.
Aber die Wohnverhältnisse ...
Ich bin sehr anpassungsfähig.
(Eigentlich hätten David und Thomas
vor drei Jahren
im kleinen Rahmen heiraten wollen.)
(Aber Davids Familie
hatte andere Pläne
und es wurde
ein richtig grosses Fest daraus.)
Als die Zeremonie begann und wir
mit der ganzen Familie reinkamen,
hätte ich mich am liebsten
in Luft aufgelöst.
Mein Mund war so trocken,
meine Lippen klebten an den Zähnen.
(So schnell geheiratet
hätten sie auch,
weil es das Zusammenleben als
binationales Paar einfacher macht.)
(Dazu sind in Kanada Hochzeiten
gleichgeschlechtlicher Paare
inzwischen selbstverständlich.)
Das sind sehr schöne Erinnerungen.
* Liebliche Gitarrenklänge *
Was mich bei der Hochzeit
extrem beeindruckt hat ...
Man muss sich das mal vorstellen:
Der Altersunterschied,
ein Ausländer -
wie viele Vorurteile
könnten da vorhanden sein?
Und ich habe nichts davon gespürt
bei der kanadischen Familie.
Sie waren so ... Sie waren so offen.
Und seine Grossmutter
hatte erst kurz davor erfahren,
dass ihr Enkel homosexuell ist und
erst noch einen Schweizer heiratet.
Man muss sich mal vorstellen,
wie die meisten in dem Alter
reagieren würden.
Sie kam auf mich zu - sie hat mich
zum ersten Mal gesehen -,
küsste mich und sagte:
"Du musst ein guter Mann sein, denn
du machst meinen David glücklich."
* Lockere Gitarrenklänge *
(Grenzenlose Liebe heisst:
viel Altes aufgeben
und viel Neues dazugewinnen.)
(Endloses Schneeschaufeln z.B.,
wenn in der Heimat schon langsam
die ersten Schneeglöckchen
erscheinen.)
* Herzschläge *
Ich hatte nie das Gefühl,
etwas aufgegeben zu haben,
das ist das Schöne an dieser Liebe.
Denn wenn du das Gefühl hast,
etwas aufgeben zu müssen,
bist du nicht auf dem richtigen Weg.
Das macht man automatisch.
Für die Liebe macht man das automa-
tisch, es kostet keine Überwindung.
(Nancy und Demis führen
ein Künstler- und Vagabundenleben.)
(Sie malt Bilder
und verkauft diese auch,
und er produziert Filme
fürs Internet.)
(Eigentlich ist das ganze Leben der
beiden ein kleines Gesamtkunstwerk.)
(Weltenbummler, Erntehelfer,
Influencer und Gelegenheitsarbeiter -
Hauptsache, sie sind zusammen.)
(Für ihre YouTube-Fangemeinde
drehen sie heute ein neues Video
ausserhalb von Monterrey.)
Fährst immer du, Nancy,
oder fährt er auch hier in Mexiko?
Doch, doch, er fährt auch.
Lüg nicht, meine Liebe!
Du lässt mich nie fahren.
Und Mutter auch nicht.
- Warum nicht?
Ihre Mutter lässt mich nie fahren,
weil ich den Blinker setze
und so korrekt bin.- Was?
Ich schalte den Blinker ein,
wenn ich die Spur wechsle.
Das muss man doch.
Ja, ich halte mich an die Regeln.
Und das ist falsch.
Wechsle ich die Spur
und setze den Blinker,
wollen in Mexiko
noch alle schnell vorbeifahren,
weil sie den Blinker sehen.
Sie sagt, man muss einfach
die Spur wechseln, ruck, zuck,
dann halten sie schon an.
* Energiegeladene
mexikanische Musik *
Eine wahnsinnige Kulisse!
(Nancy und Demis
sind in Mexiko Online-Stars.)
(Dank ihrer Videos
in den sozialen Medien
kennt das halbe Land die Geschichte
des schrägen Schweizers,
der sich erst in eine Mexikanerin
und dann ins Land verliebt hat.)
Hola!
Grabando esta belleza de Monterrey.
La Huasteca.
(Die Arbeit als YouTuber
hat eher zufällig begonnen.)
(Mit selbst gemachten Videos
wollten sie ihren Freunden
und Familien zu Hause zeigen,
wo sie gerade herumreisen.)
Oh, wow, so beautiful!
Hey, I'm Demis.
- Y yo soy Nancy.
We are ...
- Somos ...
(Beide) Vagaboom!
* Liebliche Gitarrenmusik,
Herzschläge *
Sie sagte: "Nimm meine Hand
und bring mich, wohin du willst."
"Ich weiss nicht, was ich will."
Wir sind mit dem Fahrrad aus der
Kirche, sind nach Alaska geflogen.
Nancy merkte: "Hier sind keine
Touristen. Wo bringst du mich hin?"
Ich antwortete: "Du sagtest,
du gehst überall mit mir hin."
"Also kommst du nach Alaska."
Ich war damals so traurig,
dass ich sterben wollte.
So sagte ich mir:
"Wenn mir mein Leben egal ist
und du mit dem Rad losziehen willst,
dann komme ich mit."
"Egal, was passiert -
machen wir es!"
(Ihr Ziel: von Alaska
bis nach Patagonien zu fahren.)
(Tausende von Kilometern,
und alles mit dem Fahrrad.)
(Ein gemeinsames grosses Abenteuer
und ein Weg,
um die Trauer zu verarbeiten
und nach dem Tod des Bruders
neuen Sinn im Leben zu finden.)
Von Gefahr zu Gefahr hat sie
ihre Lebenslust wieder entdeckt.
"Hey, ich will morgen
auch noch leben! Das ist super."
* Gemütliche Gitarrenmusik *
(Das, was man hat,
mit anderen teilen,
auch als Akt der Nächstenliebe.)
(Das leben Nancy und ihre Familie
ganz konkret.)
(Zweimal pro Woche kochen sie
für ca. 200 Bedürftige
und Obdachlose von Monterrey.)
Das Fleisch wird hinten angekocht.
Denn sonst
erwärmt sich das Haus zu schnell.
(Ein richtiges Familienprojekt.
Alle helfen mit.)
Ja.
Esto es picante?
- Es muy picante, no?
Willst du probieren?
- Nein, danke.
Wir dachten, wenn wir den anderen
helfen, geht es ihnen besser.
Aber in Wirklichkeit geht es uns
besser, wenn wir anderen helfen.
* Gemütliche Gitarrenmusik *
(Monterrey liegt im Norden Mexikos,
nur 2 Std. von der
amerikanischen Grenze entfernt.)
(Eine Stadt
mit über 4 Mio. Einwohnern.)
(Seit bald fünf Jahren
verteilt Familie Cortez hier
selbst gekochtes Essen.)
(Finanziell geht es der Familie gut.)
(Diesen Aufwand jedenfalls
können und wollen sie sich leisten.)
Gracias.
- Gracias.
Vamos!
(Sie begannen damit nach dem Tod
von Eric, Nancys Bruder.)
(Inzwischen ist es eine Tradition,
die der ganzen Familie
beim Verarbeiten dieses
schweren Schicksalsschlags hilft.)
(Dass es hier
ein warmes Gratisabendessen gibt,
hat sich sogar bei der Polizei
rumgesprochen.)
Dos, eh?
- Sí.
* Nachdenkliche, pulsierende Klänge *
(Es ist eine schöne,
friedliche Atmosphäre hier.)
(Und ich kann nachempfinden,
dass so ein Abend
Balsam für die Seele aller ist.)
Auf dieser Internetseite
gab es ein Forum,
da äusserten Experten,
die schon viel mehr wussten,
ihre Meinung über die ukrainischen
und russischen Frauen.
Da zeigte sich mehrheitlich,
dass diese Frauen
eher noch etwas genügsamer sind
als Schweizerinnen oder Deutsche.
Dass die Frauen in Mitteleuropa
eher eine Karriere anstreben
und die Frauen in der Ukraine
noch eher dazu bereit sind,
Hausfrauen zu sein.
* Glockenläuten *
* Sanfte Zithermusik *
(Es ist kurz vor Weihnachten.)
(Lanas Mutter ist schon seit
drei Wochen in Thusis zu Besuch.)
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Ich hatte mir
anfangs Sorgen gemacht,
dass unsere
unterschiedlichen Charaktere
erneut aufeinanderprallen könnten.
Wir sind halt wie Wildschweine.
Wir sind beide
im Jahr des Schweins geboren.
Mutter ist ein Leittier
und ich bin eines.
Und wir geben nicht nach.
Aber jetzt
haben wir Frieden geschlossen.
* Fröhliche Musik *
* Sie spricht russisch. *
Wow!
- Wow! Cool!
Krasiii...
- Krasiva.
Sehr schön.
Es sieht super aus.
Ich könnte das nicht.
Ja. Sieht genial aus. Sehr schön.
Bravo.
- Okay, enough.
I ya!
I ya.
* Sanfte Zithermusik *
Hier ist die Wohnung. Das ist der
Ausblick nach draussen übers Wasser.
Wow! Wie heisst dieses Wasser?
Was ist das? Lake ...
Das ist eigentlich ein Kanal.
- Ein Kanal?- Ja.
Werden wir Geräte haben?
- Geräte?
Ja, da ist alles ... Everything
here. Dishes and everything.
Super.
Super, super, super!
Es war immer mein Traum,
nach Amerika zu fliegen.
Wir hatten Martins Bildungsurlaub
schon vor 1 1/2 Jahren geplant,
oder?
Oder war es vor zwei Jahren?
Oh, verzeihe!
Ich lebe schon so lange mit Martin,
dass ich glaube, er könne Russisch.
Als ob wir schon 50 und nicht erst
sechs Jahre zusammen wären.
Ich freue mich sehr,
im Frühling nach Miami zu reisen.
Ich bin stolz auf meinen Mann,
dass er uns als Familie diese Reise
an diesen schönen Ort ermöglicht.
Then we go to Key West
one weekend ...
(Nach 22 Jahren
an der Schule in Thusis
kann Martin Bildungsurlaub beziehen.)
(Sechs Wochen Sprachaufenthalt
in den USA -
alles ist gebucht, es fehlt
nur noch das Visum für Lana.)
(Aber auch das haben sie beantragt.)
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge
und Herzschläge *
Für mich war es ein Segen,
ihn kennengelernt zu haben.
Er hat mir eine neue Welt eröffnet,
meinen kleinen sozialen Kreis
gesprengt,
alles, woran ich glaubte.
Demis kam und sagte:
"Schau mal, das alles gibt es."
Ich war Gott sehr dankbar.
Alles, was ich mir gewünscht habe,
traf ein.
Ich war sehr verliebt.
Und jetzt kann ich meinen Weg gehen
und er seinen.
Denn wir sind beide frei.
(Heute ist mein letzter Abend
bei Familie Cortez.)
(Wir feiern das
mit einem guten Essen.)
... que bendiga mi hogar y todos los
que entren por la puerta.
Que bendiga esta comida
en el nombre de Jesús Cristo, amén.
(Alle) Amén.
- Buen provecho!
Gracias por cocinar.
- Gracias.
Gracias por cocinar, sí.
- (Mutter) Mona también cocinó.
Wo werde ich euch
in fünf Jahren treffen?
Ich würde gerne in Mexiko bleiben.
Aber um Kinder
und ein Haus zu haben,
wäre mir der Süden Mexikos lieber.
Der Staat ist etwas günstiger
und auch authentischer.
Und reisen wollen wir
zwischen Europa und Mexiko.
Schweiz, Spanien, Italien -
v.a. in die Schweiz.
Ihr bleibt Reisende.
- Hauptsache kein Winter.
Es perfecto, sí.
Aber Mexiko wird unsere Basis sein.
Salud!
- (Alle) Salud!
Viva México!
* Jubel *
Salud, salud! Y muchas gracias.
Der ÖV in der Schweiz
ist einfach sensationell.
Wenn du hier den Bus nehmen willst,
musst du erst 20 Min. zu Fuss gehen.
Dann musst du schauen,
ob der Bus überhaupt fährt.
Man hat zwei Städte
wie Winterthur und Zürich,
und am Samstag
fährt während 4 Std. kein Bus.
Dann muss man herausfinden,
wann der Bus fährt.
Am besten mit Google,
weil sie keine gute Homepage haben.
Das Geld muss man passend mitnehmen,
weil es keinen Billettautomaten hat.
Sie machen es einem nicht einfach.
- Vive le Québec!
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Thomas sagte schon,
es habe noch viel Schnee im März.
Aber ich habe es mir doch
etwas weniger imposant vorgestellt.
Das ist ja krass.
(Kanada schläft noch,
als ich frühmorgens durch das Wohn-
quartier am Stadtrand Québecs fahre.)
* Vogelkrächzen *
Ach, schau mal an!
Hallo, wer bist denn du, du Schöne?
* Schrille Türklingel *
Ich glaube, es ist schon jemand wach.
Hallo Thomas!
-Ja, hallo!
(Es sind ein paar Monate vergangen,
seit Thomas Kleiber bei mir im Radio
seine letzte Wetterprognose
gemacht hat.)
(Jetzt lebt er bei seinem Mann David
und bei seinen Schwiegereltern.)
Trois?
- Trois!
(In Québec, wo auch im März
noch tiefer Winter herrscht.)
Und all das macht Thomas
aus Liebe zu dir?
Ja, genau.
Für dich schaufle ich sogar Schnee.
Seid ihr schon eingerichtet?
- Ja, etwas haben wir verändert.
(Hier im Untergeschoss ist also
Thomas Kleibers neues Zuhause.)
Das haben wir neu gemacht,
vorher hatte es andere Farben.
Wir haben es heller gestrichen,
weil das Tiefparterre
nicht so hell ist.
Ja, sind das eure einzigen Fenster -
dann noch mit so viel Schnee davor?
Ja, deshalb habe ich ein Loch
geschaufelt. Sonst wäre es schwarz.
Dieses Loch ist nicht natürlich.
Eigentlich hätte es hier 1 m Schnee.
Es schaut jetzt wirklich viel besser
aus hier, mehr nach unserem Stil.
Es ist jetzt unser Zimmer.
"Français!"
Genau, das haben David und ich
in der Schweiz gemacht.
Das hattet ihr bereits.
- Genau, in der Schweiz.
Die Idee war, immer abzuwechseln.
- Maintenant, c'est en français.
Die Grundlage jeder Integration
ist die Sprache,
wie du dein Umfeld schaffst,
deinen Humor.
Wie du dich eingibst, wie du
Kontakt zu den Leuten aufnimmst.
(Thomas Kleiber)
Ich finde oft die Worte nicht.
Ich kann nicht
mit der Sprache spielen.
Et ça, tu fais beaucoup.
Du spielst so oft mit der Sprache.
Wenn wir mit Leuten unterwegs sind
wie gestern Abend,
fühle ich mich
wie der Langweiler vom Dienst.
Bis ich in der schnellen Diskussion
einen Satz zustande bringe,
ist das Sujet schon wieder vorbei.
Wenn man einen ironischen Spruch
bringen möchte,
muss man sprachlich präzise sein.
Das kann ich nicht,
mein Humor kommt nicht an.
Sie sind eine lustige Familie,
sie lachen oft.
Ich kann einfach
nichts dazu beitragen.
Ich fühle mich ziemlich langweilig.
Das ist frustrierend.
* Pulsierende Klänge *
(Noch etwas frustriere ihn
jetzt im Winter.)
(Diese Schneemenge kommt dem passio-
nierten Radfahrer Thomas ungelegen.)
(Ohne eigenes Auto
ist er immer auf andere angewiesen,
um von A nach B zu kommen.)
(So ist der Ex-"Meteo"-Mann derzeit
Schneeschaufler im Hauptfach.)
Hallo, hilfst du uns?
Da sind wir aber dankbar.
Du hilfst uns beim Schaufeln?
- Wir sind schon fast fertig.
Dumm ist, dass es weiterhin schneit.
Hinter dem Haus
mache ich dann weiter, siehst du.
Wir stehen hier auf 3,5 m Schnee.
- Unfassbar. Bis das alles schmilzt.
* Lachen *
Nicht schlecht, oder?
- Das ist super.
Was man halt so macht in Québec.
Komm!
- Hey bravo!
* Lachen *
(David arbeitet unterdessen
im Café seiner Familie in der Küche.)
(Dass Thomas noch keinen Job hat,
sieht er entspannt.)
Voilà.
Wenn er jetzt noch nicht
arbeiten will, verstehe ich das.
Er wird bestimmt eines Tages etwas
finden, das er wirklich gerne macht.
Wir müssen das beide
ganz entspannt nehmen.
Ich bin glücklich,
dass ich ihn unterstützen kann.
Es ist eine schöne Gelegenheit,
ihm davon etwas zurückzugeben,
was er mir gegeben hat.
* Herzschläge *
Klar kann man Dinge planen.
Aber das heisst nicht,
dass es dann auch so funktioniert.
Ich glaube, bei ihr sind Spuren
ihrer Jugend zu erkennen,
aus dem System des Kommunismus,
in dem sie aufgewachsen ist.
Da gab es noch
Fünf- und Siebenjahrespläne,
die durchgezogen wurden, auch wenn
alles chaotisch und scheisse war.
Sie haben am Plan festgehalten,
obwohl sie Schiffbruch erlitten.
Sie hat 20 Jahre in diesem System
gelebt, das ist sicher prägend.
Better dead than red.
Better dead than red, ja.
(An diesem Morgen haben Martin und
Lana aber alles minutiös geplant.)
(Sie sind auf dem Weg
zur US-Botschaft in Bern.)
(Für Lana als Ukrainerin ist es
nicht einfach, in die USA zu reisen.)
Was ist das? Ordner files ...
Ich kann das nicht absagen.
Es ist alles gebucht.
Auch meine Stellvertretung
ist organisiert.
Ich kann das
nicht mehr rückgängig machen.
Wenn sie die Aufenthaltsbewilligung,
das Visum nicht bekommt,
muss ich halt allein fahren.
Entschuldige, Martin!
Ja, ja.
- Ich dachte ...
Ich sagte, es seien drei.
Aber es sind drei wichtige
und zwei mit anderen Dokumenten.
Alles perfekt.
Don't worry, be happy.
* Sanfte Balalaika-Klänge *
Here's your queue. Okay? So ...
- I will go.
Good! Okay.
* Langgezogene Gitarrenklänge *
So etwas macht mich immer nervös.
Aber ich sehe keinen Grund, weshalb
sie das Visum verweigern sollten.
* Sanfte Westerngitarrenklänge *
Okay. And? Alles okay?
- Yes, yes, everything is okay.
Cool, okay.
- So let's go.
(Hürden überwinden und Neues anpacken
schweisst zusammen.)
(Das nächste Ziel von Martin und Lana
heisst: Miami.)
* Herzschläge *
Jetzt muss ich schauen,
dass ich es durchs Ohr bringe.
(Im Alltag bleibt nicht mehr viel von
der früheren indianischen Kultur.)
(Umso liebevoller
pflegen die Stammesmitglieder
jene Traditionen, die es noch gibt.)
* Sanfte E-Gitarren-Klänge *
(Das Powwow findet in Fort Belknap
statt, in der Bingohalle.)
(In Fort Belknap leben 7'000 Menschen
mit indianischen Wurzeln
aus zwei verschiedenen Stämmen.)
* Indianische Gesänge und Trommeln *
Ich bin jedes Mal aufgeregt,
bei jedem Powwow.
Nach den ersten paar Tänzen
lässt die Nervosität nach.
Ich weiss nicht weshalb.
Es ist so etwas wie Lampenfieber.
* Indianische Gesänge und Trommeln *
* Rhythmisches Trommeln
und Nachahmen von Vogelkrächzen *
Wenn Brigitte mit mir tanzt,
wird mein Herz leicht.
Es überkommt mich auch eine Wehmut,
denn die Frauen unseres Stammes
tanzen nicht mehr.
Brigitte ist zwar
nicht Native American,
aber sie ist meine Seelenverwandte.
Die Leute akzeptieren das.
Das ist das Gute,
wenn du die Frau findest,
mit der du zusammenleben willst.
Sie ist die meine.
Wir glauben,
dass wir vorher zusammen waren
und für immer zusammen sein werden.
In einem nächsten Leben vielleicht
nicht in dieser Form, aber zusammen.
Wir sind einander vertraut.
Wir gehören zusammen.
In unserem Alter haben beide einen
Rucksack mit Lebenserfahrungen -
mit guten und schlechten.
Man bringt eine Prägung mit sich,
daran muss man manchmal arbeiten.
* Rhythmisches Trommeln *
(Weisse Bärin aus der Ferne -
so haben die Nakotas
Brigitte getauft.)
(Und vielleicht geht sie bald
dorthin zurück, in die Schweiz.)
(Diesmal jedoch zusammen mit Jay.)
(Wir wünschen den beiden
nur das Beste.)
Dafür braucht es Gefühl!
- Kennst du einen Trick?
Dreimal hier, zweimal da?
- Mit Gefühl!
(Demis und Nancy
sind zu Besuch in der Schweiz,
bei Demis' Mutter in Birmensdorf.)
(Sie musste sich damit abfinden, dass
sie ihren Sohn nur selten sieht.)
(Bereits vor gut zehn Jahren, als
Demis packte und auf Weltreise ging.)
Die Reise dauerte länger und länger.
Irgendwann habe ich verstanden,
dass er jemanden kennenlernen und
nicht mehr nach Hause kommen wird.
Aber als Mutter ist es hart.
Das möchte man ja nicht.
Man hätte gerne
eine Schwiegertochter, die hier ist.
Aber bei einer so tollen Schwieger-
tochter gebe ich ihn gerne her.
So, stellen wird das hier hin.
Mama, ich mache
ein paar Instagram-Storys.
Una, dos, tres!
Das habe ich gehört!
(Ob in der Schweiz
oder zu Hause in Mexiko,
Nancy und Demis teilen alles
mit ihren Fans auf Social Media.)
(Manchmal posten sie
ganz Alltägliches
und manchmal teilen sie mit uns die
wirklich grossen Momente des Lebens.)
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
No manches!
No manches, amor!
Was ist passiert?
- Schliess die Augen, Mama!
Gib mir deine Hände!
Jetzt darfst du die Augen öffnen.
* Romantische Melodie *
# Take my hand.
(Und so gross ist das Glück.)
(Wir gratulieren Nancy und Demis
und sind jetzt schon gespannt,
wo sie das Leben
als Familie hinführen wird.)
(Nach Mexiko, in die Schweiz
oder an einen ganz anderen Ort.)
(Zu Hause sind diese beiden
so oder so auf der ganzen Welt.)
# Oh take my hand.
Weshalb habt ihr
so früh geheiratet?
* David imitiert
ein schreiendes Kind. *
(Dass man unter 8 Mrd. Menschen
den richtigen für sich findet,
ist per se
bereits ein kleines Wunder.)
(Und wenn der oder die eine
am anderen Ende der Welt wohnt,
braucht es gleich noch einmal
ein Wunder für ein Happy End.)
Das ist riesig.
- Ja, es ist gross.
(Die Frage bleibt wohl
für immer unbeantwortet,
was einen genau dazu bewegt,
alles hinter sich zu lassen
und Ja zu sagen.)
(So wie es Thomas und David
an genau diesem Ort machten.)
Du sagtest, du wollest
nur eine Hochzeit im kleinen Rahmen.
Da siehst du wieder, wer
in unserer Beziehung das Sagen hat.
Ja, genau.
Das ist wirklich
wie in "Vom Winde verweht".
Wie waren die drei Jahre,
in denen ihr zusammengelebt habt?
Man darf es fast nicht sagen:
Wir sind sehr stolz auf uns.
Ich finde, wir haben das beide
extrem gut gemacht.
Auch was danach kam,
die Herausforderung.
Auch unsere Familien und Freunde.
Immer ist einer von uns weggegangen,
es war immer ein Hin und Her.
Wir waren teilweise
monatelang voneinander getrennt.
Ich finde,
wir konnten sehr gut damit umgehen.
Wir sind sehr stolz.
Es gab schöne Augenblicke,
aber auch schwierige.
Ich will nicht verheimlichen,
dass es auch
diese schwierigen Situationen gab.
Dass wir es geschafft haben,
das macht mich sehr stolz.
Wir passen einfach super zusammen
und ergänzen uns gut.
Er würde dich immer
und immer wieder heiraten.
(Thomas)
I would do it again.
(David) Me too, really.
* Lachen *
(Thomas) Der Kleine!
* Er ahmt das Ächzen
der Anstrengung nach. *
Cute!
Hallo!
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Wow! Das sieht schon ...
- C'est cool, hein?
David, was wünschst du dir
für eure gemeinsame Zukunft?
Ich wünsche mir, dass wir uns
nicht zu viele Sorgen machen.
Dass uns die Zukunft nicht belastet.
Dass wir zusammenbleiben
und dass es uns gut geht,
egal, wo wir leben werden.
Ob wir wieder in die Schweiz
zurückkehren oder hierbleiben,
lassen wir das Leben
und unsere Gefühle entscheiden.
Was wünschst du dir? Was ist für dich
das Wichtigste für die Zukunft?
Ich wünsche mir,
dass ich es schaffe, hier in Québec
Dinge, Orte und Menschen zu finden,
bei denen ich mich zu Hause fühle.
Dass es mit der Zeit Dinge gibt,
an die ich mich erinnere -
wie auch in der Schweiz -,
an Geschichten, Menschen und Leben.
Ich wünsche mir,
dass ich auch hier ein Zuhause habe
und in der Schweiz Sehnsucht
nach Québec und Kanada hätte.
Schauen wir vorbei?
- (Thomas) Ja.
# It takes me, breaks me,
tears me up inside.
# But when you smile,
your beauty shines so bright.
# It moves me, you choose me,
wherever I may lie.
# You say: "Go on and tell me
where you wanna go tonight."
# Break out the sad songs
and take them on your ride.
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich mich
nicht aufopfern musste.
Wenn du glaubst, dass es Aufopferung
ist, dann ist es keine Liebe.
Liebe gibst du automatisch.
Gerade noch die Kurve gekriegt!
Erstens: niemals aufgeben
und daran glauben,
dass eine Person da draussen ist,
die für einen bestimmt ist.
Man soll nicht angestrengt suchen,
das funktioniert nicht.
Es geschieht,
wenn es geschehen soll.
Ich sage ihr jeden Tag:
"Ich liebe dich." Jeden Morgen.
Ich berühre sie immer wieder.
So bleiben wir verbunden.
Wir beenden sogar
gegenseitig unsere Sätze.
Ich liebe ihn so, wie er ist.
Er ist gutmütig,
grosszügig und intelligent.
Er ist einfach mein Mann.
Es wäre natürlich schon cool, wenn
ich ihre Sprache sprechen könnte.
Es wäre auch eine Wertschätzung
Lana gegenüber gewesen,
wenn ich etwas besser Russisch
gelernt hätte.
Das hätte ich anders machen sollen.
* Meeresrauschen und Möwenschreie *
(Und dann,
als der Film schon fast zu Ende war,
erreichte uns vom anderen Ende
der Welt eine wunderbare Nachricht:
Auch in Neuseeland
gibt es Nachwuchs.)
(Katja und AJ erwarten ein
Geschwister für die kleine Narja.)
# Together we will be
forever you and me.
# Take my hand.
(Hin und weg - wir lernten
viele Menschen kennen, die zeigen,
dass Liebe Grenzen und Hindernisse
überwinden kann.)
(Die Sendung ist zu Ende, doch
ihre Liebesgeschichten gehen weiter.)
# As long as you are there.
# Take my hand.
# Together we will be
forever you and me, take my hand.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Alexandra Duttweiler - 2020